j'avais ils seront demain les
ambassadeurs de la bonne alimentation
ses élèves du lycée hôtelier de saint
quentin en yvelines visite ce jour là la
ferme de la une hier à son chant
spécialisé notamment dans l'élevage de
volailles l'occasion pour ces jeunes de
découvrir le parcours de la ferme à
l'assiette ils se sont rendus ensuite à
l'atelier de transformation valeur à gaz
rang qui permet à l'exploitant de vendre
directement ses produits c'est
intéressant parce que c'est beaucoup de
produits qu'on travaille nous que ce
soit au lycée ou en stage et du coup bas
savoir dire ça provient comment ça fait
c'est important c'est nous du coup
souvent on aller par exemple en termes
de poulets par exemple on a beaucoup les
poulets bas soit entier soit en les
vidant sais pas vraiment comment c'est
fait comment s'est nourrie comment ils
s'en occupent toute l'année et c'est
donc
c'est toujours très enrichissant de
pouvoir partager son expérience en tant
qu'agriculteur et encore plus avec des
des futurs engagés dans la vie et dans
la restauration parce que c'est comme
cela qu'on commence à faire comprendre
l'intérêt du travail de proximité et de
deux peut-être mais des futurs contacts
visible dans le cadre du projet e repas
table porté par la fédération française
des maisons de l'europe il s'inscrit
directement dans la stratégie européenne
pour un système alimentaire plus sain
équitable et respectueux de
l'environnement repas table vise à
sensibiliser des actions ont été menées
auprès des lycéens du corbusier à poissy
par la maison de l'europe des yvelines
les élèves du lycée hôtelier de 50 ans
ni vigneron peut participer à un
concours projet fédéral sur toute la
france et qui va permettre à un binôme
de l'école hôtelière de participer à un
concours national en mars prochain à
louviers en normandie
le binôme sera sélectionné 10 6 février
et concourt à face à des participants
venus de toute la france les finalistes
devront préparer un repas pour six
personnes en mettant en valeur des
produits normands tout en y ajoutant une
touche de gastronomies européennes